ich will nicht too hot to handle bei der
serie geht es darum dass fünf heiße
typen und fünf heiße mädels auf einer
einsamen insel sind und sie bekommen
100.000 dollar wenn sie einen monat lang
nichts miteinander haben und ich habe
gerade heftig doch auf einen tisch
geschlagen bisschen mit meiner letzten
action auf tour zu händeln sind wir auf
jeden fall an der stelle stehen
geblieben wo die gerade einen workshop
abgeschlossen haben der die näher
zusammenbringen soll
allerdings nicht auf ebene sondern auf
geistiger ebene und da schauen wir jetzt
mal weiter nachdem sie beim workshop
versucht honda ihre gefühle zu entwirren
wären sharon seine unter einem großen
orangefarbenen kisten versteckt
ja wir sind direkt mitten drin ich mag
dich wirklich ich will dich richtig
kennenlernen
ich hab schiss mission rohner zu
verknallen meine ex verließ mich für
meinen besten freund und haben mein herz
gebrochen
was will ich nie wieder durchmachen
ja da kann ich verstehen dass er liebe
gegenüber so ein bisschen resistent ist
aktuell ich habe gefühle ist ehrlich zu
mir schätzen weiß
ehrlichkeit es wirklich mit das
allerwichtigste
allerdings muss man natürlich sagen wir
befinden uns gerade in folge 3
also ich denke die beiden werden auf
jeden fall zusammenkommen oder wenn ich
so gern gerade es ist schön mit dir du
bist ein toller mensch
[Musik]
das war mal einen korb auf einer ganz
anderen liga alter er drückt ihr so voll
seine gefühle für sie aus und sie so
eher unsere lampe mal schauen was sie
diesmal wieder für ein problem hat das
geld warten
ich erahne ein armer bauern
ich sollte nicht so oft stoppen
ich glaube nicht dass aus uns was
ernstes werden kann
ja ja
[Musik]
du wurdest ganz böse gefressen so und
gerade ist ein netter typ aber irgendwie
nicht
na klar dass die lampe wieder auf
punkten steht das ist ärgerlich kann
weiß nicht wann das zum letzten mal
passiert
also bei mir gefühlt jede stunde wer
selbst mal wieder top ich dachte
wirklich dass zwischen den beiden was
ernstes bei rumkommt weil die waren ja
auch die ersten die dieses date da
hatten das lief eigentlich ganz gut
obwohl das ende war da nicht mehr
sondern auch dieses komische mit dem
verknoten das war ja auch nicht so gut
bei denen aber die beiden nochmal heute
wurde viel vertrauen aufgebaut und
gekittet noch jana hat neuigkeiten geht
das alles zunichte machen können und
diana wisst ja noch gar nichts von dem
kuss von jessica und hayley dann den
habe ich auch schon voll vergessen
wieder ich finde dass uns jemand
beschuldigt müssen wir darüber lachen
und dürfen nicht gereizt reagieren
münchen sind ziemlich abgestoßen
[Musik]
hallo haley und francesca bitte begebt
euch mit den anderen zur feuerstelle
jetzt wird es interessant an alle unter
euch die das nicht mitbekommen haben die
beiden haben ein problem mit den meisten
anderen aus der gruppe weil die beiden
so ein bisschen die unruhestifter sind
sagen die anderen
weil laut harry hat francesca den ersten
kuss damals initiiert obwohl sie
eigentlich harry warum das von francesca
nicht cool deswegen hat francesca mit
hey hier oben gemacht und das ist schon
so verstrickt und wir sind hat man folge
3 unfassbar
naja egal auf jeden fall wird der kurs
von denen jetzt wahrscheinlich von lana
vorgestellt und die verlieren wieder
3000 euro preisgeld
ich hoffe was gutes ja aufzusetzen
mädels krass ich bin so gespannt
ich bin so gespannt es kann ja auch sein
dass lana einfach direkt sagen wir die
auch francesca und handy haben rum
geweckt
und damals einfach jeder der sich nicht
lange bis es gab einen regelverstoß und
das preisgeld wurde entsprechend gekürzt
man sieht jedem so an von wegen werden
wir haben uns alle daran gehalten was
wäre ein drama ohne eine gute
nebendarstellerin
oh mein gott sie ihr seid so mein kummer
wie die sich dann aufräumen
er war es ja gerade jeder 300 euro
verloren
durch euren dummen kurs um die anderen
fünf schätzbar das gibt nicht klar aber
wenn du noch darüber reden da hätten wir
wenigstens nicole ist rein herzens und
respektiert landers regeln ich bin so
neidisch ich will auch
irgendwie will ja niemand etwas von ihr
also no fronten nicole bist ein
wunderhübsches mädchen aber irgendwie
spielt sich gerade die ganze serie ab
mit diesen neuen leuten und dann gibt's
noch nicole und dies irgendwie da aber
irgendwie auch nicht so wie das obst im
kühlschrank
man nimmt immer nur die leckeren sachen
und irgendwann denkt man dann so 8
hinten liegt ja was aber dass dann auch
schon vergammelt und so sie ist das obst
im kühlschrank ich bin schockiert
hey komm halt nicht ausgereift das war
total affig war sie da abgezogen hatte
ich habe dadurch zwar überhaupt kein
nachteil aber mich trotzdem auf weil sie
die gruppendynamik komplett zerstört
haben strafe muss trotzdem sein ok hat
3000 dollar verloren also nochmal ein
kuss es war ein kurs ich meine das nicht
böse aber was war mit der erdbeere
wieder wichtiger doch so wie scheiße
eingewiesen und sie ausgespuckt
ja das war kein kurs frauen sind mich
war es nicht
er war es auch nicht ich frage mich ob
diese raushauen was ist mit euch
ja ich frag doch jetzt nicht jeden gibt
es doch einfach zu verdammte kacke nicht
1 hasse dann beschuldigten ihr
verheimlicht
wirklich was war netzte nach dem dann
wieder gar nicht weiß die spielen das
gerade einfach noch ein bisschen rum mit
dem lied wer was macht und geld sind die
haben auch geld verloren die stehen
dadurch um keinen will und keiner hat
sie haben selber geld verloren
sie stehen dadurch auch nicht besser bei
der gruppe da es hat quasi nur negative
auswirkungen nur negative es hat absolut
gar keinen sinn gemacht hier nicht mit
einer beziehung aus
die schar an die schaufel wegnehmen
bevor sich sein eigenes grab gräfenroda
das komplette her zu zehn milliarden
einzelteile das preisgeld beträgt nach
94.000 dollar was als nichts das
wichtigste ist dass wir ehrlich sind wir
zu unseren fehlern stehen das ist das
allerwichtigste handy bleiben regen mich
so auf erreicht sagen wir gehen die bei
nacht ihr entlarvt werden ich dachte die
sagen
wer hat allwissenheit vielleicht gehen
wie geht es meiner heutigen tour zu
henry action überhaupt nicht um
irgendwelche intimitäten zwischen den
leuten da untereinander sondern nur um
drama und ich hasse drama und will dass
die beiden mädels dass jetzt endlich mal
auflösen ich vertraue haley und
francesca kein stück die ich auch nicht
relativ sste person im haus hängt mit
der dümmsten frau der welt rum
world
dieses teilt aber aber ordentlich
aussieht da keiner ein problem hier ich
jesus ich sehe er nicht
ich sehe das problem das ist genau mein
blick den ich die ganze zeit in mir
trage mich richtig aus und richtige
zicken krans wieder abziehen nach
scharons schockieren der offenbarung am
lagerfeuer will honda
verständlicherweise antworten das ist
sonne die folge heute ist das eine sache
zu fragen ob ich es mal mit dem finger
zu zeigen
ich habe das gefühl du hast eine mauer
um dich um ich bin eine mauer
ja okay du bist ein guter mensch und
eine tolle frau aber wir kennen uns noch
nicht
sehe ich genauso will einfach nicht dass
man mir noch mal das herz bricht ich mit
meinem besten freund beschissen nie
wieder führen was ich damals geführt
jahren ich glaube aber trotzdem dass
schon und länder zusammenkommen werden
am ende wie sieht ihr da stimmt mal oben
up interessiert mich überhaupt nicht ob
mein herz sagt mir erinnert sich an
seinen schmerz die habe durchlebt fast
den kopf sagt ist ein toller mensch ja
krasse gedanken kann ich
hundertprozentig komplett nachvollziehen
dass er da sagt aber bruder muss sich
auch weiterentwickeln du kannst du jetzt
nicht nie wieder drüber ich habe mich an
mein therapeut alter komm mal klar luca
wurde das verstehe ich aber die ist das
einmal passiert dreimal so wie das geht
hat rein heiratsalter aber das ist krass
dass sie beide diesen schmerz hatten
deswegen wollen sie beide das nicht im
anderen antun geht weg aus dieser show
heißt auf das geld kommt einfach
zusammen hätten traumpaar
wie kann gott ich kann nicht von mir
verlangen dass du auf mich warten lässt
mich nicht umsonst wenn er auf machen
würde weiß ich nicht ob er der mann ist
den ich brauche ich habe gänsehaut leute
das endlich anlegen darf als ich mir die
erste episode von dieser serie namens
finger weg hin zur tenne angeschaut habe
hätte ich niemals gedacht dass ich in
der dritten folge
hier stehe und mir denke bitte krumm
zusammen ich habe gänsehaut bitte sag
ich da nur an der stelle mich mal heute
gibt's wieder ist allerdings auch
beenden meine lieben freunde wenn euch
mal wieder meine reaktion auf die hände
gefallen hat und zeigt mir gern mit
einer bewertung unter dem video hier
schaffen wir 50.000 like ich weiß es ist
eine große zahl aber es wird mir zeigen
ihr feiert die serie eine 3 action also
gibt dem video gerne daumen hoch jetzt
befinden uns allerdings auch schon im
auto meine lieben freunde wenn ihr noch
kein abonnent von meinem kanal seit und
auch in zukunft keine videos mehr
verpassen wollt dann klickt auf den
smiley denn dadurch könnte main kanal
kostenlos abonnieren werde teil der lu
crew erste crew und hier ist ein video
verlinkt was ihm auf einem kanal online
gegangen ist
also könnt ihr auch gern drauf klicken